good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
thursday hope everyone's having a great
day
i'm having a chaotic day so far my
always a journey always a journey my
morning just got turned upside down i
just want to tell you guys what happened
quickly so you can understand the
headspace that i am which is frantic
it's giving claire crawley
okay so this morning and i've been
feeling recently like it's time to start
letting brew
out of the crate when mommy leaves the
house you know i mostly i'm home with
him but i do come to the show every day
and he goes in the crate he knows that
he's going he goes you know and it's
actually like a really good schedule for
him i just wanted is a great schedule
for him but i've been realizing more and
more like it's time for him to take the
next step and to be left out of the
crate so i was like you know what this
morning is a good time to do it i'll be
gone a few hours he knows i'm coming
back like it's not a random time of day
so i do my thing i leave him out i leave
the house i'm checking the dog camera to
see if i can see him i couldn't see him
yet i'm in the uber and i'm checking the
dog camera i still can't see him but i'm
hearing noises it sounds like
something is happening you know these
are nefarious dog noises they're
nefarious and he wasn't making the noise
it sounded like he got into a package of
some sort i was like oh i must have left
you know like one of my
packages by the door and he's trying to
open it whatever i get out of the uber i
run home
and i get home and he got into a pack of
cheetos he deserves it which like we
keep all of our snacks in the same place
forever he's never jumped that high to
get one of the snacks so like the second
mom leaves the house
necessity is the mother of invention he
had this master plan like he's like i'm
getting those cheetos when i have free
time so
suffice to say brew is back in the crate
thank god you went back because who
knows what else he could have gotten
into he would have finished a bag of
cheetos and then he would have went for
his next taxi the chocolate's like
dangerous no
you guys it was too soon he was not
ready this man was not ready so
it's back to the crate for brew but we
tried and that's really all that matters
and i just want to say like mother's
intuition like i i know there's
intuition those sounds were not correct
no you knew they were nefarious sounds
and i just i love you still i thought we
were somewhere that we aren't and that's
okay
you definitely jump the gun no i mean
like it's hard people say like at one
year they're fine to start
being on their own but you know every
dog is
different like you i think i think you
measure or take a lot of notes from
magnolia but magnolia is like was
brought up by a single mom like she has
a different type of energy like magnolia
is
tough
bruno is like a little bit of like a
spoiled brat like he's spoiled with love
what do you mean he's mommy's king you
work from home you and like for as long
as you you've had him like you and zach
have pretty much both worked from home
like he's spoiled in a sense like he's
never had to really deal with any
adversity yeah so he's just different
and that's okay it's okay you know what
it's okay it works for us he'll stay in
the crate he loves the crate and so
he's he's safe he's sleeping off those
cheetos right now good good good good
and i'm just upset because i can't eat
now you don't have any cheetos now i
don't have any cheetos devastating it is
that was probably the hardest part but
um i'm glad that you know it all worked
out and then i went home otherwise i
would be so anxious sitting here like no
yeah
no it's not enjoyable no not enjoyable
let's
scratch at bruce's
bruce chase in the crate yeah um well
this is our last in studio show for the
week because i am headed to the airport
right after this to go to la for
literally like two days but i am very
excited i've got my lukes put together
and it was not easy you guys like i am
just
i'm wedding fatigued like or just like
black tie event fatigue like i've
searched every website i've worn all my
possible dresses went to one wedding no
i've been to like literally six weddings
in the last couple months
where
all over i went to one in the hamptons i
went to yes one in rome i went to one in
long island i went to one in totally
ride six months maybe less than that i
went to telly ride like i've been to a
million [ __ ] weddings
and i have four this weekend that's just
not how i see you as someone who's
always at a wedding well maybe that's
something you need to work on because
i've literally been to so many [ __ ]
weddings and that's literally like my
cross to bear for being so popular
okay
and being such a great wedding guest
like you who wouldn't invite me yeah i'm
really like if you invite me to your
wedding like you're getting your money's
worth like i will eat everything you
paid for i will drink everything you
paid for i will dance to the band that
you paid for i will close this place
down wow so like who wouldn't invite me
you know and i like i'll put you on my
instagram too which is always just like
an added bonus that's true i'm a premium
guest that's very true you always have
to think about that like i mean i got
married so young like i didn't even know
what i was doing but if i was planning a
wedding now like i would evaluate every
single guest based on what value they
bring to the wedding not like oh well
she's from you know middle school no
[ __ ] that are you gonna bring value or
not right but you haven't seen like
middle school diana in so long like
maybe she turns up that's hard to know
that's true
but i think it's still a fair way to
assess like if you're getting married
like do a value check on all your guests
yeah no that's definitely true you can
definitely invite some people who okay
you're not that close but like you want
them out there on that dance you want
that energy yeah yeah 100
so i'm going to another wedding this
weekend
um but i'm very excited for this one and
yeah that's where i'm going after this
so tomorrow's episode will be podcast
only i do apologize but there will still
be an episode yeah so no worries and
tomorrow will be like all about the new
music because
there's just a lot to process and you
know what's so nice is like for most of
the new music i'm gonna be in la which
means i'm gonna get it at nine o'clock
oh that is nice which is such a
privilege that people on the west coast
like never talk about they're always
complaining like bachelor spoilers
really like you get music literally
before you go out for dinner like it's
so nice that is interesting all we hear
is like the negatives you know never the
positives
[Laughter]
it's twisted for sure for sure for sure
so how was your night last night my
night was good i went to dinner with tpg
and tyler c and it was just like i've
never felt so short in my life i
actually wore
the biggest pair of boots i saw that i
bought yesterday and it was just like
it was a lot you know like my the two
loves of my life but it was really fun
and i have a terrible headache
but i'm pushing through did you drink a
lot or if this was an unearned headache
no i definitely earned it okay i didn't
drink like a lot but i didn't drink a
little
okay that's good but you know there's a
custom egos blanco shortage
do you know no
i know for the last oh right
for the last like couple months pretty
much every restaurant in the city like
does not have custom egos and if they do
they don't have blanco there's like a
major shortage in the new york area
like everywhere i go so i've had and you
don't understand like it's all i drink
that's there's not like really another
option doesn't even know what it's due
to sure like just supply chain that's
like everyone's talking about supply
chain like that's literally how the
supply chain is affecting me
so
when i go places it really makes it a
huge problem for me so when i go
somewhere and they've done julia blanco
like that i will drink that but at the
restaurant we went to last night they
didn't have don julio blanco so i just
kept getting drinks with like different
tequilas like trying them all
um
i had 818 blanco in a margarita and i'm
so sorry like it was disgusting like i
couldn't believe it because i'm drinking
it like in shots before i don't think
it's like a good tequila to make
cocktails with okay but it's good for
shots it smells like chocolate like it's
so bizarre but it's good for shots yeah
that's probably more important it's just
good on its own but when i took a shot
with it once i was like blacked out it's
like i probably would have drank
anything
um
then i had casa dragonese
which was like okay
but a little smoky which is not my
favorite and then i got really [ __ ]
desperate and i drank ha ha and it was
some of the most disgusting [ __ ] i've
ever drank in my life wow so i was like
just desperate and then i went to then
we went to another place afterwards that
had like um don julia blanco but are
other city states experiencing this
shortage it's really affecting me i mean
these shortages are out of control it's
the first one i've been
in contact directly in contact with or
directly affected by you don't see it
like when you're grocery shopping
i don't really go grocery shopping oh
okay
so yeah unless like there's a shortage
on ubereats it's probably not gonna
affect me you know
yeah i understand um so that's my drama
and i think that's why i have like such
a weird headache like it's i've had it
like placed in the center of my scalp
you have you have a cosmic headache and
eight one eight headache yeah you're
gonna see and then i have the haha
like
done julio how do you get the ha ha yes
so that's why i had it because i i
basically drank like five different
liquors it was just like and then i got
so many drinks because i just kept
hating them this is yeah so i was like
let me get another one finish this one
until i landed
and it was
it was a journey but you know what
that's life you know yeah adversity yeah
but i came through on the other side wow
that really sounds torturous it kind of
was and i was like i guess i could just
switch to like wine or like literally
anything else but i i don't drink
anything else i'll i'll just not drink
yeah there's got to be one other thing
you have to have a backup no i know but
like i don't a beer
okay i'm not going to dinner with tyler
c you know he would love him
claudia you're not like other girls not
like other girls yeah
i do tyler drink
red wine classy red red one
and brian drank like a little bit of
everything he started with martinis
brian's like such a big guy like it
doesn't even faze him it's different
it's like him drinking a pellegrino is
him drinking a martini it's the craziest
thing yeah um so yeah it was a lovely
evening and
that's like my jam okay cool well we've
got a lot to talk about today i spent
the night watching the cma awards so
that will be our first story all the
winners when i got back from dinner i
watched like every clip on youtube so i
feel like i was there okay cool no it
was it was really exciting to watch it
was back at full capacity it was the
real deal everyone it felt like everyone
was there in every category all the
nominees were present so it's like
anyone could win it it was really
exciting to be a part of country music
like respects the cmas i feel like all
these pop music award shows are so like
obviously rigged
nobody goes to any of them except the
grammys and still even the biggest
artists don't go like yeah
country music like they really kind of
like look out for one another they all
show up for the cmas and that's why the
cmas are successful and you'd love to
see it you love to see it so without
further ado i think we're just gonna
jump right into the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
hydrodrug you guys need to get your
hands on the water bottle everyone is
talking about the hydro jog it's
seriously one of our new favorite items
they're durable and reusable they hold
more than half a gallon of water so you
will stay hydrated all day long so yes
they hold half a gallon of water they
have a leak-proof seal a wide mouth
opening so it makes it really easy to
add ice or fruit or whatever you want to
add um it also has an integrated handle
because chugging looks cooler
one-handed
it's dishwasher safe shatterproof and
it's just great for keeping you on track
with drinking your water and carrying
around with you leaving it at your desk
taking with you to your meetings um it
comes in like tons of cute colors it's a
great way to just stay hydrated gamify
and a lot of celebs are using the
hydrodrug so that's pretty much all you
need to know
um you can get your hydro drug at
www.thehydrojug.com
and use code toast to get 10 off your
order hydro drugs are game changers for
anyone on the go again use code toast at
the
hydro
jug.com to get 10 off today and start
hydrating today
thank you claudia first story the cma
awards 2021 a full list of winners and
then we'll talk about some of the
performances the big award of the night
entertainer of the year went to luke
homes so deserved it was the only award
that he won during the broadcast last
night was the first time we like heard
from him on stage aside from his
performance of his new song which is so
good which was so beautiful and stunning
by the way he probably thought because
he didn't win any awards like he
definitely wasn't winning because chris
stapleton was winning everything his he
won song of the year album male vocalist
and it just was feeling like okay it was
chris's night this is chris's night but
i guess luke and i would agree was more
entertaining this year than chris
stapleton i never understood how you can
have the album of the year be the male
vocalist of the year and not be the
entertainer of the year but that's
happened to luke like in previous years
he's won so many of those big four
categories and not one entertainer it's
a little different though because it's
like to be the male vocalist of the year
like that's just about your pipes like
whose pipe sounded the best i don't know
if it's about singing abilities it's
about vocals
like really if you're getting down to it
and then the entertainer of the year is
is about everything it's about the shows
it's about social media it's about
commercials like you know so you can be
one and not the other yeah i guess i
mean we've been waiting for this for so
long like i have a very very um
vivid memory of last year me and margo
were at tpg's house watching and they
were like luke and miyamoto started
screaming and i forgot that luke bryan
was nominated and it was like luke bryan
like just moronic but he is an
entertainer of the year he hosted last
night you know he does american idol
that's the sort of thing that get like
he's been entertaining all year yeah i
guess but like still with with kovid no
one was doing more than luke home six
feet apart putting out music as
frequently as he could killing it on
social doing all these live streams like
he was the entertainer of the coving
year and you know what i'm glad he
didn't win it because who the [ __ ] wants
that like right this was a real year
this was a real show
fans were there there'll be crowds and
there'll be shows and there were and so
it was just so beautiful obviously like
his winning moment like he was really
surprised i think we all thought it was
just gonna be chris stapleton again yeah
he hugged nikko
he went up to the stage he was so
nervous like he didn't really even like
say anything i i agree i did not think
he said i've never written a speech for
a moment like this i never thought it
would happen he was just shook to the
core i'm just obsessed and you know what
i realized something about luke last
night when he was making a speech and
when he was singing his performance you
know the thing ben does with his feet
it's not pigeon toed i've learned i was
pronouncing it wrong it's opposite i
think it's duck footed okay
or
yeah whatever he does it i think that's
why i'm so attracted to him so now that
makes it okay that ben's doing it now it
makes it cool now every time you trip
over his foot you'll be like oh nico
goes through the show
um yeah he i was so
i just couldn't believe it you know
we've waited so long for this like we
are o.g luke comes like we've been with
him since day [ __ ] one and it just
feels good to have like the
the benefits of our hard work like to
finally pay off yeah yeah no it felt it
felt so good it was the perfect way to
end the night
then also uh female vocalist of the year
was carly parse someone else who did not
think she was going to be winning it was
such a pleasure to watch her
freak out freak out like
and you know what's nice about carly
parson i felt this way for a really long
time like when when we first you know
entered the nashville scene
everyone in nashville like has so much
respect for her like the way they talk
about her like she's the most
hardworking everyone just has this like
mutual admiration and respect for her
and you have to wonder like what what
that's all about and i think she's just
like a really hard-working girl yeah so
it's nice to see someone
have their hard work pay off yeah no it
was um and i didn't really know who was
going to win this category female
vocalist i didn't have a horse number of
course in this race gabby barrett
miranda lambert ashley mcbride marin
morris carly parks so i would have been
happy with anyone me too i mean i was
happy to see it go to someone who really
really didn't think yeah to have that
like moment of
which we rarely get these days of like
holy [ __ ] especially at the cmas because
for a while it was like the same five
people winning every award yeah and
especially in female categories it was
always miranda lambert or carrie
underwood which they're both deserving
of but like we could change it up every
year yeah the male vocalist of the year
was chris stapleton i felt good about
that especially because even though you
guys know i'm not like a huge chris
stapleton girly i'm i'm not against him
in any way it just never
stuck for me but his performance was
like head and shoulders above everyone
else he performed on his own and then he
also performed with jennifer hudson and
like he is the male vocalist of the year
the thing about chris stapleton that i
[ __ ] love
is he is weirdly and no one really talks
about it because he's so [ __ ] low-key
he doesn't like take paparazzi pictures
like he's like he is so [ __ ] famous
he literally sells out arenas like in
the same way that like beyonce and
taylor swift do like he has the biggest
following everyone wants to work with
him he's on red he's on adele's album
but he's so country and he's never once
wavered like he goes to cmas every year
and he goes to the grammys but he's so
country and he's like so proud of his
country and i just [ __ ] love that
about him yeah no he he was giving us
everything last night and i fully
understood and i was i was not upset
with his winnings but he's like the most
low-key artist and most people don't
realize i think he has like similar
sales
album sales and ticket sales as like the
biggest artist in the country yeah he's
like garth brooks literally
like he does arenas single of the year
went to starting over by chris stapleton
the best song of all time album of the
year went to starting over by chris
stapleton well deserved what other
albums were nominated 29 by carly parse
dangerous by morgan wallin that was
never going to win part by eric church
and skeletons by brothers osbourne so
people are really upset that morgan
wallin didn't win he was also
abandoned
from coming walking the carpet
performing etc but he was allowed to be
nominated i guess well i mean
his album is the country album of the
year right it broke all these streaming
records um all these country album
records like critically it was so good
the fans loved it even when like they
were running through the nominations in
the
broadcast and people were cheering for
each nomination like the cheers were
through the morgan fans are not happy no
they're not happy and and you know what
when it comes to album of the year like
that actually i think in my opinion was
the biggest country i mean numbers wise
it was and it's not just about the
numbers but musically it was stellar it
was really good so this is like a i
don't know where we go from here like
where does morgan go from here he's back
on the road he's doing shows
around the country yeah um
i don't know where we go he like tweeted
i think today that he's just like
thankful for his blessings and thankful
for tomorrow like not being like sour
about the whole thing but the fans are
pissed the fans are pissed the bands are
like putting up billboards like the fans
are crowdfunding like i haven't seen
billboards and stuff i was just seeing
like on twitter because it's it's pretty
glaring no of course his absence and i
guess this was the only category he was
nominated in um he could have been
nominated in other categories too but
they just really i just think it's weird
that they're gonna ban him but still
nominate him like
go all the way or don't no but
you can't ignore the music like and the
the place that it helps i wonder how
long that's gonna last right is this a
one year ban well actually i think it's
been two now no it was the album came
out in january yeah but no like his
incident his incident was just a few
weeks after the album came out oh okay
so it's only been one cma yes this is
the first cma yeah okay
we'll see yeah we'll see
song of the year went to starting over
chris stapleton
vocal group old dominion the vocal duo
brothers osborne okay i need to talk
about this for a minute because
obviously i would literally lay down on
a train track for brothers osborne like
give them my virginity obsessed
and i'm so glad they won is there a butt
coming
no oh you're so glad they won so glad
they won even like just i think they
deserve to win they're literally
releasing the most stellar music
but
tj osborne getting up and winning and
kissing his boyfriend was the most i
know it doesn't seem like a big deal
it's historic like that's never happened
in country music and i just thought it
was a stunning moment for everyone it
was a stunning moment it was a great
night for the brothers osbourne they
performed younger me which is a song
that like could make me cry i know so
i'm just so everything makes me cry but
like that song even before i was
pregnant it came out yeah it's just like
so beautiful i try and make people
listen to that song like everyone should
listen to it it's so good and so it was
just a great night and a great moment
and as tj said in his speech like love
wins and he was just so happy to be
celebrated and it was it was beautiful
yeah and i thought you were going to say
like you're glad they won but like
should have gotten like
[ __ ] no absolutely not like i stand
brothers osbourne until the day i die
like i'm so happy for them and it was
just this one little moment but it was
huge like you never see that and it was
just it was amazing yeah it was amazing
i literally have a screenshot of it on
my phone that's so cute well because i
was like happy but then also kind of sad
that he had a boyfriend because i've
been like trying to set him up like
sliding in his dms have you really but i
literally have a screenshot of it on my
phone cutie
new artist of the year went to jimmy
allen and he performed freedom is a
highway which is the best [ __ ] song
and someone needs to pick it up for a
car commercial yes it reminds me of the
song that came out of um
songland that was um for who
for the jeep commercial young
i don't think i know it uh you do
because i'm always playing it okay well
also about jimmy allen i just think like
the more i've like dancing with the
stars is fully rigged like jimmy allen
of course got sent home literally last
week he had to go to cma awards oh kenny
moore litter got sent home the week real
houses of atlanta started filming like
it's fraudulent
interesting or maybe they're just
throwing around because they're like i
gotta get back for the cmas no
no no also jimmy allen speech was like
so
so sweet what he said he just like
talked about his journey like moving to
nashville that like five years ago at
the cmas he spent his last 100 so he
could come see uh charlie pride perform
and then last year what's up i'm gonna
cry last year he performed on stage with
charlie pride and like it just
thanked his wife and his kids and that's
just being so cute
yeah so those were all the awards that
were announced on the broadcast um two
that weren't announced but were both won
by kelsey ballerini were
musical event of the year and music
video of the year half of my hometown is
an amazing song with kenny chesney and
kelsey ballerini it really is and she
was serving looks last night she is
constantly serving look she actually
does a really really good job no like
she her red carpet look was so
incredible and then she presented in
another incredible look and she really
brings like couture she does she takes
it seriously and we really appreciate
that but i thought everybody was looking
great last night everyone was looking so
close individually like doing their own
thing and i was very into it yeah any
performances that were a highlight for
you
literally luke homes and lucam's only
like it was [ __ ] gorgeous it was
incredibly gorgeous also carrie
underwood and jason aldean i didn't know
they had a song together yes they do and
they very much enjoyed that song it's
really good yeah and then jennifer
hudson just i didn't see that so i'm
actually
planning on watching like all of this on
the plane okay cool i brought my ipad
cool no the performances were great it
was just really nice to be a part of
something last night that's how i felt
like to not be watching a reality show
just like to be in music biggest night
country music's biggest night it people
are saying i saw people saying on
twitter like it really is not the same
ever since the morning chose didn't do
the red carpet this year but
you know we were limited and we weren't
an ass back but we're limited in our
capacity and we'll be back we'll be back
and i thought luke bryan did a cute job
posting yeah
he's cute
no matter what like you always end up
finding the house annoying like just
yeah yeah but like he brought out enough
people that like he diluted himself yes
okay are you ready for our next story
is it the next story that's brought to
you by organifi yes it is a line of
organic superfood blends that offer a
plant-based nutrition made with
high-quality ingredients
each organifi blend is science-backed to
craft the most effective doses of
ingredients that are organic and free of
fillers and contain less than 3 grams of
sugar per serving like the organifi
green juice with essential superfoods
and a clinical dose of ashwagandha it
helps reduce stress support healthy
cortisol levels and organifi gold a
superfood tea that supports rest and
relaxation so you can wake up feeling
refreshed each organifi blend is easy to
use by simply mixing it with water or
your favorite beverage while on the go
they don't compromise quality for taste
organifi takes pride in offering the
best tasting superfood products on the
market at a price that will work out to
less than three dollars a day
you can experience organifi's high
quality superfoods without breaking the
bank go to organifi.com toast and use
the kotos for 20 off your order that's o
r g a n i f i dot com backslash toast
and use the code toast for 20 off any
item so if you're just like drinking
water and you want to be making better
use of your time getting all these great
vitamins superfoods just throw an
organifi in they actually taste really
really good and it's a premium
experience so check it out great okay
next story alec and hilaria baldwin dine
in new york city at trendy sushi hot
spot bond street a missed
amid the rust shooting lawsuit so page
six obtained exclusive photos of the
couple departing new york city hotspot
bond street where they dined with
hilarious hair stylist on wednesday
following their trip from vermont also
one of the producers on the movie is now
suing um alec and really yeah for
emotional distress caused by the
shooting
okay i want to say something i think
that
hillary and alec are probably handling
this like the worst any two people could
handle anything and i think they're just
so toxic but i do think people are being
like a little unfair like
like oh they're out to dinner how could
they like
you still have to eat like you know what
i mean like i think people are really
taking like advantage of this situation
just like criticizing everything they do
but they do make it so easy because
they're so hateable
yeah you know
i don't know because it's hard not to
compare this
to like the travis scott situation okay
i mean
no i don't agree with that at all
they're not the same by any means but
it's it's a similar
tragic event
no i don't agree with this celebrity who
is
partially responsible no i don't agree
in what way i don't think alec baldwin
is responsible at all like i think that
you don't think he's responsible at all
no i don't think he knew there was a
real bullet in the gun do you
i don't know what he knew oh no i think
this was like literally a horrible
horrible accident and like he's probably
traumatized
i don't think he's responsible at all
like i don't think i would compare these
two situations at all i i just keep
thinking about both of them in tandem
because they're also just happening at
the same time right and it's like a
death involving a celebrity yes and it's
just interesting to see the way that
other people are talking about it too
i i see what you're saying but i think
they're so different like i don't think
they are they are so different i'm not
saying that they're
exactly the same like tit for tat but
just it's there's kind of similar
circumstances because you're saying you
didn't know out you didn't think for one
second alec baldwin knew there was a
bullet i'm not saying he did or he
didn't but other people were saying like
i don't think travis scott knew what was
happening okay even if that were the
case travis is still responsible like
for the environment the culture like not
taking proper precautions before even if
he had absolutely no idea up until he
was at dave and buster's like even if he
had no idea that anyone had passed away
or was in danger he is still incredibly
responsible i agree i was actually
talking about it yesterday with someone
and what i was saying was i don't i
personally and i saw people were like
you're defending travis because you're
kylie stan kylie has nothing to do with
this yeah i personally don't think that
travis knew what was going on or saw
what was happening or like how bad it
was and continue to perform because i
don't think that he's that an evil right
but considering the environment he
fosters at his shows he should have been
looking for it right or having people on
the ground who are looking for it yeah
no like he should have you take the time
to make sure like everyone's good here
you see something that looks like he
should have been looking for it i don't
think he saw it but he should have
yeah no i i have a hard time believing
like people are that evil like i agree
with you um
but even so i still hold him incredibly
responsible for the situation even being
a remote possibility because of the
environment he fosters and the like
violence he encourages like i think he's
100 responsible with the alec baldwin
thing like i really believe and again we
have no idea what actually happened on
that set like who put the [ __ ] real
ass below why is there even a real
[ __ ] bullet on a set right i have no
idea
but i believe
alec baldwin had nothing to do with it
like i despise alec baldwin i don't
think he's a murderer i i don't think he
had anything murdering a woman with a
child like i don't think he had anything
to do with the real
bullet in the gun and that this in any
way was intentional
but two weeks ago
you killed someone accidentally and now
you're at bond street no i feel that i
feel that but i do think that like
no i guess actually when you put it that
way you're 100 right now like so i'm not
saying like uh no i mean i think that
they're
handling this like
horribly like the tmz video on the side
of the street
i agree
but like people have to eat so like
you know
yes
i agree i agree he has every resource
available to him like fondry to
somewhere you go to like be spotted on
dumas no literally so that's why it's a
little
surprise it's a strange choice yeah no
it's bizarre for sure like it's a trendy
place like with your hair stylist for
sure
but again they are like not normal i
don't know what the [ __ ] they're doing
like they're insanely stupid and i and i
despise them but i do think
and again we really don't know what
happened on that set i do think it was a
complete act like maybe not accident
maybe someone did plant the bullet
on alex part like i don't think he's
running around murdering mothers yeah
and so just the crew member is suing
alec and the armor for negligence after
the shooting so that just came yeah i
need a documentary on this because i'm
like i understand there's an armor the
investigation is ongoing and we need to
just wait for the investigation to play
out because all these things that we
don't know like they should be figuring
out yeah who brought the bullets where
did they even come from like if you have
a fake gun on set why would you ever
need a real bullet even remotely close
i don't know and i agree i guess like it
is really tacky like when there's like a
family morning and like you're out upon
street i feel that that's all i was
saying yeah no it's a full circle moment
like order in
get a pizza doesn't lauria love to cook
she can't remember the uh cute cucumbers
hillary sorry i did not mean to call her
ellaria okay it goes against like
if someone in my presence calls her
laura like i will not expect i did it
multiple times oh [ __ ] i was also just
reading the article like my name is
hillary she is of no spanish descent
like lest we not forget yeah
our next story scott disick has been
spotted with a new woman again and he's
approaching something that remotely
looks like an age-appropriate
relationship
it's better what is she 24 she's 23
and he's 38. okay the thing is when
you're 23 she's legal drinking age legal
drinking age and when you're 23 like
you're still a child but you're almost
like i was married when i was 23. that's
an interesting point yeah so like but
again i don't know if i'm like the best
example for like maturity and adulthood
but 23 is better but it's still like
you're 38. dude a 28 year old like yeah
something and you can still be 28 and
really hot and tight and curvy like it's
not exclusive to the 18 year olds or 25
we're brain fully formed brain fully
formed 25 i agree i think anything under
25 is questionable just jurisdiction but
i'm glad to see that they can go to a
club together and she doesn't have to
bring her fake id right also she is
brooklyn beckham's ex her name is hannah
cross when i heard that i literally
thought of the tick tock sound don't you
feel
stupid you're literally dating a
teenager's ex-girlfriend like it's so
bizarre that is true i haven't thought
of it like that it's so weird yeah
well we'll see where this one goes who
is this girl she is a um
a girl a girl
and she's alive yeah i don't know okay
well she's just like she's just being
labeled as brooklyn's ex like oh that's
so sad yeah
um okay well whatever 23 is better but
it's still not great and it's just a
pattern of behavior that i find so
bizarre yeah i agree i'm not here for
the pattern but at least we're getting
warmer
yeah and i think that like people
a lot of people i think they were really
put off by the amelia thing like
really and i think it was not that he
cares but i think it was like really bad
for his image like the way that that
picture and just like their overall age
gap i think people were really really
put off by that i mean i i've been put
off and i'm a huge fan of his yeah so i
think like he stepped it up a couple
years like just so people wouldn't just
like jump down and start again not
because this is the great love of his
life
and you couldn't even just step it up a
few more years 25 like that's literally
it i will do anything like
snatchler
she snatched she's 24.
doesn't make that she's going on 25.
okay he can call her in may yeah may 6
to be exact
okay are you ready for our next story i
am yes i am lala ken is speaking out on
the randall breakup she said i mean i
forgot that like that was real i know
and and i want to talk about where we're
at today on this it's been a few weeks
do you need to get a plane ticket
because are you in denial no i'm not in
tonight okay let's
talk about what she said and then let's
talk about what we'd like to see for her
okay
and then let's project our delusions
onto our podcast audience stop it the
vampire by the way don't forget to
subscribe to our youtube channel oh yeah
the vanderpump rule star spoke out about
her breakup from the movie producer on
her podcast wednesday and says she's
leaning into her role as a mother to her
daughter ocean she said i take it one
minute at a time because a seven month
old can't sit around and wait for you to
get over [ __ ] right you better keep your
[ __ ] head up and do your thing so
that's what i do
she admitted that she never thought that
my life would be where it is right now
and that's okay but that she's
appreciative for her daughter and her
book release keeping her distracted from
the pain of the split yes girl promote
the book yes girl with my job.
you have to be grateful for every
experience because what i've been
through in my life which people have
been through much crazier and traumatic
things than i've been through those
people inspire me who deal with the
things with grace and they come out on
top even with the hand that they were
dealt that is such a good way of looking
at things like my situation like
obviously sucks but like it could be so
much worse i'm like looking at your
blessings as opposed to like your
curses i guess yeah um
she's just like has a really good head
on her shoulders she really does
and i feel sad that like
we're here but you know what she like
obviously got into a relationship with
someone with a lot more money than her
and i feel like she never like got lazy
she never let it be like her fall black
like she never let it get comfortable
like she's like i know he could leave me
in the way that i got him she was always
saying that she has her own career she's
got the la la makeup la la baby the book
i think she's a podcast
show where she said these things right
so you know what i think
it she could be in a far worse situation
because i know a lot of situations like
that like you get comfortable you think
this is your life and then you don't
work and
and you have nothing left yeah so i
think she's actually in a pretty good
situation i would agree now do you think
would you how would you feel if they got
back together
fine i mean you know when there's a
child involved crowd research oh no i'm
kidding i think i would feel fine mostly
because there's a kid involved like if
your parents can be together like
wouldn't you want that for some for
ocean yeah i just feel like especially
with the way that this season is airing
like she couldn't do it
because of the way that people would
come for her you know what i mean i
don't know like
even though it's not a reason and a way
to live your life no like tom and katie
have been to get through far worse you
know yeah and we don't even know what
happened honestly right we just saw some
girls in a hotel right he probably
[ __ ] him like let's just be realistic
like we're all adults it's okay
and so
is lala able to get past that yeah i
don't know but whatever would you say
did you get past that
with the father of your daughter and
maybe you know
if he was financially
set like would that help it would help
for me for sure i don't know that's i
hadn't thought about it as me yeah i've
only thought about it as her not a zach
just like a total hypothetical situation
yeah you just had a baby with a guy with
a lot of money get the [ __ ] out of my
face yeah and he cheats on you like
while you're literally breastfeeding um
but he wants to come back he says he's
sorry and he has a lot of money like
what do you do no
i don't know money talks
just saying
think about it i don't know
to have like a seven month old i know it
can't keep it in your pants it's like so
[ __ ] up you stand no chance no yeah
people like that are
i know everyone's capable of change but
like those people are not yeah like if
you're literally [ __ ] some random
girl why your wife is breastfeeding your
newborn baby like you're an animal yeah
you're an animal i agree so but how much
money do you have like i need numbers
like for real though if
ralla got back together i would i do
really kind of ship them i really do
especially now that we're getting so
much of their relationship on the show
it's like the first time we're seeing it
so at the same time i'm falling in love
with them as a couple and they're
deteriorating that's why i forgot that
they're broken up because i literally
watched two nights ago them having
generally savannah problems so it's very
confusing for me yes it is confusing but
as she said she's taking it one day at a
time i feel like she's made no decisions
and you know what take your time yeah
she'll see how she sees she'll see how
she feels yeah
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
it's the final
[Music]
it's the final story
prayers go up to la la
today's fifth and final story is brought
to you by olive and june the best
manicure system out there okay stop
paying for overpriced manicures when you
could literally do them at home with the
best system of all time so the olive and
june mani system is the answer to salon
perfect nails at home their polish lasts
over seven days and it does not chip and
with their manicure system
every at-home manicure comes out to just
two dollars and we have obviously a
discount code but let me tell you about
the manny's system
you do it yourself if you're not going
to chewing your nails you think you're
not but then you get the set from
olive and june and they have this little
silicone topper that goes on top of all
the nail polish bottles that makes it so
easy to like steady your hand especially
if you're painting your dominant hand um
they've got nail files cuticle oil it's
literally just all-in-one things you
always are looking for in your house
like when you're breaking are you like
do you have a nail file well if you have
the alvin dude manny set even when
you're not doing your nails you always
have a nail file on standby
you're getting salon perfect nails at
home that lasts over seven days
and
it comes with all the tools you need
it's five steps comes with a poppy which
is that patented brush handle that makes
it easy to paint and it's really really
affordable with six polishes breaks down
to just two dollars a manicure and you
can get 20 off your first mani system
with you
when you use code toast your new nail
life is here 20 off your first manning
system when you use promo code
toast.olivenjoon.com
that's olive and june.com promo code
toast check it out
i mean it
great
our fifth and final story youtube is
removing the dislike count on all videos
across its platform
youtube announced that its decision to
make the dislike count on videos private
across its platform the decision is
likely to be controversial given the
extent that it impacts the public's
visibility into a video's reception but
youtube no i i don't think that's true
at all but youtube believes the change
will better protect its creators from
harassment and reduce the threat of what
it calls dislike attacks
essentially when a group teams up to
drive up the number of dislikes a video
receives that's like when people go to
the podcast app and like leave you like
a double review yeah no i i don't
understand why they're hiding it like
just get rid of it right could they say
that that while the disk like counts
won't be visible to the public it's not
removing the button itself users can
still click the thumbs down button on
videos to signal their dislike to
creators privately so you can privately
be you know to be harassed yes wait
that's moronic right you're not
protecting anyone's mental health you're
actually making it worse like i guess
you're making them feel more isolated
like
so funny it's like deal with your shame
by yourself
that's horrible just get rid of it right
this is what's the problem with all
these [ __ ] apps like they do all
these [ __ ] like pr stunts like
actually stop harassment and they do
nothing like this is so stupid this is
counterintuitive i mean this is really
really senseless like honestly just get
rid of this does yeah or don't or don't
but get rid of it like yes you should be
doing everything possible to combat
people getting harassed and like they do
that to youtubers like they'll dump
tons of dislikes and it's just like bad
for your brand like
get rid of it yeah this is the stupidest
thing i've ever heard you you still get
access to how many people dislike you
look good no one else will know i guess
that helps but it helps but it's still
like the same thing of you're being
attacked oh my god that is the crazy
stupidest thing i've ever heard in my
life and the trolls do still get that
like feeling of dis i'm getting to you
yeah just get rid of it yeah
did facebook used to have a dislike no
no they just they invented the like they
mentored the like and then they gave you
other emojis you could like
ha ha yeah cry crying hurt angry yes
yeah
okay yeah that's like so stupid but um
this is the stupidest thing i've ever
heard in my life like dead ass yeah from
a billion dollar tech company like
that's the best you could do to combat
harassment and also like people will
find other ways to let you know that
your [ __ ] is just no don't worry like
the trolls will literally
climb every mountain
sail every seat to let you know that
they're fat that you're fat and they
hate you right like why can't they just
then write a comment that says just like
right now maybe now like i guess because
the dislike button is anonymous you
can't see who disliked it so if you
wanna i mean you could always have a
bank account but like if you wanna use
your no but like your fake account is
connected that's the thing about youtube
it's connected to your gmail so like if
you have to be if you wanna be a [ __ ]
youtube troll you have to make a whole
new email account and that is dedication
and you know what
you're a big loser like yeah that's it's
insane dedication to troll someone on
youtube because most people are
automatically logged into youtube with
their like work account like they don't
make
new subscribers yeah yeah no but i guess
like disliking something was like a no
strings way to troll yeah and now you've
got to put yourself out there put
yourself out there and then you would
know how it feels literally and then but
you don't
yeah
okay cool i'm glad that that's that we
flush that out that's that
that's that on that um and that's our
show i mean like i have to go to the
airport oh it's so early like that's the
worst you can come hang with bro see how
he felt about those cheetos and i'm just
going the opposite direction
oh damn yeah brutus
well we hope you have a great trip thank
you other people hearing everything that
goes down i will be taking notes keep
your eyes open ears open
legs open check check double check yeah
um so yeah i'll be back on monday
tomorrow's episode is podcast only it'll
be up
i don't know what the time difference
i'll have to figure it out but it'll be
up it'll eventually later so that's our
show you guys thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast monday
morning show where we deliver the fast
five stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i heart
radio cast box all the places wherever
you listen to podcast financial morning
toast leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are and
if you made it to the end of this
episode congratulations why don't you go
drop an emoji on our most recent
instagram to let us know that you
actually listen to the whole episode
because you care about your girls um and
let that emoji be the bearded man in
honor of chris stapleton and luke combs
taking home many awards that's beautiful
throw a man with a beard it could be
santa could be just a regular guy with a
beard it's up to you get creative love
you guys we'll see you tomorrow or
you'll hear us tomorrow bye